can you believe it we've made 50 of
these dumb things
from the guy who made Batman comics cool
again and the guy who probably make
Batman movie suck again comes a film
based on a graphic novel based on an
older film based on ancient Greek
propaganda based on a true story 300
before the release of the unnecessary
sequel on a boat revisit the movie that
made guys everywhere feel really out of
shape meet the Spartans a society built
on Reason sit-ups and child abuse led by
Leonidas cinemas Y Elias King males from
the Scottish part of Greece we've been
sharing our culture with you all morning
watch as Leonidas and his 300 closest
gym buddies stand against the bite of
Xerxes a hairless giant with an entire
jewelry store on his face and a voice
that sounds like he's in the witness
protection program
I will lace up your sandals for a blend
of historical truth and Zack Snyder nods
ends mixing real Greek battle formations
with crazy ninja spin moves real Spartan
councils with sexy stripper Oracle's and
actual Persian fighting units with
mutant Persian goat men huh boy Allah
for the most confusing thing to happen
to teenage boys since calculus class
full of homoerotic undertones like men
wearing thongs then getting speared with
phallic objects men holding hands been
holding men tenderly from behind then
letting it hang
then getting all wet in the rain men
getting all sweaty on the beach men
playing two flutes at the same time men
saying things like this find thrust for
this your opinion rivals will kneel at
your feet wide open and a male to female
nipple ratio of six hundred to four man
I haven't seen a movie this deep in the
closet since Top Gun
so get pumped for a dumb movie that's
only cool because of Zack Snyder's bag
of overused visual tricks featuring
dramatic falling stuff
Instagram filters
and super come on I might as well be
reading the book starring Gerard but
Nick Fury 6 through 300 doll scene
Emperor PT hey you guys Cersei Lannister
McNulty and Michael Fassbender 301 cool
looking movie now he gets to make Batman
vs Superman great thanks for watching
our 50 and honest trailer who knows
maybe someday we'll make it to 300
get it please don't forget to subscribe
get your stinking paws off me you damn
dirty ape
swiggity swag what's in a bag everything
is awesome everything is cool when
you're part of a team I'm not famous
anymore it's my duty to place that booze